then we get whoopi goldberg the specter
of look b goldberg saying that we have
to suck it up you know we sucked it up
when trump won
in what way did democrats suck it up
when trump won we got four long years of
you whining that trump wasn't the actual
president of the united states
not hashtag not my president the women's
march in the immediate aftermath of
trump winning
we we got huge black lives matter
protests throughout the summer
the idea being that trump was the the
fond head of systemic american racism
we got the media and their collusion
narrative that went on for years on end
despite lack of evidence
we got an impeachment at what point did
democrats actually come to terms with
the fact that trump had won they never
came to terms
which is why they're so celebratory now
because they think that now reality has
snapped back into place
but spare me like really all of this
stuff is just
all these people who are unwilling to
accept the results of election now going
you know you guys you got to grow up i'm
not i'm not willing to hear that from
you i'm sorry whippy goldberg i'm i i
think you have um
i think you literally have no leg to
stand on here this is well not literally
i assume you have legs but you have no
leg to stand on here here's whoopi
goldberg
when you know who was elected four years
ago
you know hillary clinton didn't say hey
wait a minute this doesn't feel right
stop the count she didn't say this isn't
right i'm not going for she didn't say
any of that so all of you suck it up
suck it up like we sucked it up and if
you are not sure that you're comfortable
with joe biden
do what we did find things and then take
it to the law and if the law says it's
something to look at
look at it but from now on suck it up
okay that is literally what is happening
right now people are literally going to
the courts
they're literally filing affidavits okay
so in the meantime
attorney general william barr he has put
out a memo to
assistant u.s attorneys all over the
united states
telling them that if they see credible
evidence of election fraud then they
should investigate it this is being
taken by the media
as a sign that william barr has
militarized on behalf of the trump
campaign
literally he changed no legal standard
okay so the headlines are
william barr initiates investigations in
the meteor like yeah but we don't see
any evidence of serious widespread voter
fraud that's not the letter says so
here's what william barr's letter
actually says he's the attorney general
here's what he actually says and by the
way
people are saying that this is him you
know basically trying to please
donald trump that this whole thing is
about him trying to appease donald trump
because donald trump doesn't want to
accept that he lost the election or
something
what if the reason that william barr is
doing this i mean here's here's a
possible take
what if the reason william barr is doing
this is because number one there may
actually be credible allegations of
voter fraud out there that are worth
investigating and two
if there are not it is good for the doj
to be on record saying that they were
investigating those things so people
feel more safe and secure after the
election is over
did it ever occur to anybody that the
reason this process exists is so that
when the election is over people at
least
are able to point to the court cases and
to the investigations and say they
they came up empty right it turns out
the mueller investigation
it was bad and was badly predicated but
the mueller investigation did justify
trump's claims that there was no
collusion
made it very difficult for democrats to
claim there was collusion well after
this election let's say that the doj
comes up with no serious allegations of
widespread voter fraud
it's gonna be a lot easier for people to
point to that and say okay there was no
widespread voter fraud that decided the
election
the purpose of the process is not to
come to a preset end
the purpose of the process is to ensure
the integrity of the elections